[Music]  check it outside  [Music]  I gotta tell you something pal you still  got it you got every move though you  with dent I'm sorta tight friend she  believe me story for another time  dude these three pigs were in we're out  where you say you serious really yeah  who's this it's called a car mate no  it's a wheelchair with a real frenchie  it's clean it's quiet and doesn't smell  like your ass on the inside all right we  have to first then Las Vegas does the  English shoe salesman nobody's talking  to of noise possible around so you  already prepared the Redis let's have it  if the bad to mr. French dump violence  brothers I'm done I'm with varnas what's  that supposed to make it be no more  hurting my fellow man  bang-bang  [Music]  good job with the non-violence thing but  why attend real good job that might  impressive  [Music]  [Music]